hey guys today is a special day because
I just want to sit here and talk with
you guys and do a Bible study
now today we're going to talk about what
it means to grow spiritually stronger in
God as a man and how to do it
and it's special because I'm gonna do
the Bible study with you
and it's part of my new book called bold
Pursuit a 90-day devotional for men
seeking the heart of God and I want to
work through day 14 which is about
capable and equipped now I'm going to
read here from the ebook and yes it is
available as an e-book so if you live in
a country where you cannot get the
physical book the hard copy then you can
get it online as an ebook or if you
drive far distances you can get the
audible version as well I've done a
whole voice over just for you guys now
let's get into this day 14 capable and
equipped all scripture
not just some of it all scripture is
inspired by God and beneficial for
teaching
listen carefully for rebuke for
correction for training in righteousness
so that
the man or woman of God may be fully
capable equipped for every good work it
doesn't say half capable it says fully
capable which means the Bible gives us
everything
that we need to be able to live as Godly
men and godly woman it is the word of
God which he already chose to reveal to
us the logos and that's in 2 Timothy 3
16 to 17.
now we live in an amazing time
we can access vast amounts of
information with just a few keystrokes
and even now with AI
times are changing so fast
yet that creates unrealistic
expectations for most of us
especially when it comes to Life's most
pressing questions
why did God let this happen why doesn't
he answer my prayer
what's his plan for my life we get
frustrated and discouraged when we don't
receive immediate answers
now I'm not preaching to you guys
because sometimes I'm guilty of this as
well
because
I don't follow God's will I want to
follow my own will and I want things to
get done I want God to answer my prayers
and I want it done my way and that's not
right we should follow God's way all the
time we should follow the example of
Jesus
when he prayed not my will be done but
yours be done
and Jesus said if you want to follow me
then you need to deny yourself
pick up your cross and follow Jesus if
you don't do that then you cannot follow
Christ you cannot be a disciple and I
say here we get frustrated and
discouraged when we don't receive
immediate answers and that is because
we're acting in the flesh we want
immediate answers we want our will
instead of focusing on God's will
but look at 2 Timothy 3 16 to 17 which
describes the process of spiritual
maturity
teaching rebuke correction and training
these things require time and effort
it's not things that will happen
immediately it requires time and effort
they call for patience and diligence and
they show us important truths about God
and His word first God wants us to rely
on him
not on ourselves on him
when Moses led the people of Israel to
the promised land
God provided just enough Mana every
morning to sustain them for that day
God wants us as his people to come to
him daily for our needs he breathed out
scripture because he wants us to turn to
his word every day for guidance and
wisdom this is so important
we live in a day and age where a lot of
people move away from God's word
and listen
to preachers who preach to itching ears
to false preachers and they don't know
God's word when I ask a lot of
Christians do you know the Bible have
you read it at least once they say no
even though they've been Christians for
years
but Jesus says that if you love me you
obey my Commandments but how can you do
that if you don't know his word
you can't
you see if you want to become
spiritually stronger
you need to go to the Cross first
and then to God's word
because Hebrews 4 verse 12 says for the
word of God is sharper than any
two-edged sword cutting to the division
of
Soul and Spirit this is where you get
the difference between
your soul life your fleshly nature and
the spiritual nature where you can
become stronger is by reading his word
to read it write it on your heart and to
live it not just to be hearers of the
word but to be doers
second
the harder we search for something the
more valuable it becomes to us
Proverbs 2 compares the wisdom of God's
word to a treasure
like all good Treasures
it's not easily discovered we must
commit to searching the Scriptures Daily
that's like the good bereans right who
searched the Scriptures Daily to see if
these things were so we have to dig sift
and dig some more
the harder we work to discover God's
wisdom
the more we appreciate it when we find
[Music]
you know
my dad was a wonderful man I was blessed
by God to give me my dad because he was
a preacher but he he lived the way he
preached
and all the sermons I heard from him the
Bible studies together as a family
all the things I learned from him
they were like seeds put in my heart and
now when I'm older I start to understand
it because it starts to to grow into
plants into a beautiful garden
and this is so true the harder we work
to discover God's wisdom the more we
appreciate it when we find it so now I
start to understand things that I
couldn't understood before because I
wasn't spiritually there yet
but now a lot of the things that my dad
said because he was a spiritual man a
mature Christian he understood a lot of
things that I don't but now I'm starting
to understand more and more and it
becomes
more special to me now I appreciate it a
lot more
third spiritual maturity is rarely what
we imagine
our quest for God's wisdom is often tied
to a specific situation we want to know
how to deal with a pressing problem or
receive guidance in making a decision
now listen carefully but God has
something much bigger in mind
these ways are not our ways
he wants to make us capable and equipped
for every good work not just for this
thing that you have to take care of for
every good work
so he gives us more than we ask for
because he knows what we need
he shows us perspectives we could never
see on our own
in 2 Corinthians 12 7 to 8. Paul said he
prayed three times for God to take away
the thorn in his flesh
Paul likely believed he could be a more
effective Christian minister without his
affliction
but God helped him see that his physical
weakness actually made him a more
effective minister
this is this is amazing because it shows
us that what we think is best for us is
usually not what's best for us God who
is perfect we are not perfect The God
Who is perfect who's not even controlled
by time space or matter he lives outside
of it because he created it he can see
the future he knows what's best for you
he knows exactly what we need all we
need to do is to fully trust him not in
ourselves but in God knowing trusting
that he knows what is best for us
[Music]
fourth God's timing is perfect
this is something that you will always
need to remember
he Reveals His truths when we need them
and when we are ready to understand and
apply them this is so important
we may read a certain Bible passage the
same way 10 times in a row But as time
passes we grow in our faith
when we are ready God May reveal a piece
of Truth in the passage
that we have never noticed before that's
how we grow I talked about this just a
little bit earlier on the example that I
use with my dad certain things that he
talked about scripture that I didn't
understand but now as I'm slowly
maturing into a mature Christian I'm
starting to understand it
and let me tell you there's still so
much more that I don't know
you know walking on this road of
sanctification with God is like
a gold mine you know you you just see
there's a gold mine and you're here at
the beginning and you start to see that
the goal but then when you look inside
you see man there are tunnels leading
everywhere and there's not just gold
there's diamonds so oh man it just
doesn't stop
and that is it
you will never stop to grow spiritually
but while you are on this road of
sanctification you need to understand
that God's timing is perfect and that
you cannot force God to do certain
things when you are not ready for it yet
let's continue
we plant the seeds by spending time in
prayer and in God's word But ultimately
God determines our right of spiritual
maturity when we abide in him
John 15 verse 4 right abide in me
without me you can do nothing
[Music]
you know
the older I get the more precious this
becomes to me Jesus you know you can
take the whole world but just keep Just
Give Me Jesus that's all I need
I just want to abide in him know him
more deeper Fuller Jesus
always only Jesus everything else this
world the things of this world it will
pass away
[Music]
all that matters is your relationship
with Jesus and I can't wait for that day
when I will stand in front of him
seeing his face talking to him
oh man
uh
I can talk about this the whole day but
let's continue
now this is
the Bible study of day 14. we just
finished it but at the end of every
Bible study day
I asked people to dig deep this is where
you examine yourself
where you look in the mirror and where
you are brutally honest with yourself
there's two questions that you need to
ask yourself here
as we grow in spiritual maturity we
become more dependent on God
ask yourself the following questions and
answer them truthfully
one do you change the Bible to fit in
with your lifestyle or do you change
your life to fit in with the Bible
huh
this is so important because
remember Jesus calls us to deny
ourselves to pick up our cross and
follow him that means we put him first
in everything
we don't put ourselves first the way we
want to live this short temporary World
in this world in this life and now you
all know about the chaos that's going
out on out there in the world where
people say my truth is my truth your
truth is your truth and
truth is hard to find
they don't even know how to define a man
or how to define a woman anymore they
want to change everything
and it's more important than ever to
stick to God's word to go back to the
Bible
and I want to say this to a lot of you
who are in churches and in ministries
who are focusing on
what is happening in the world
what is now in what is modern uh plans
things to figure out systems to work to
to get more people in the church and
maybe you at home as well I need to try
the the 10 steps to do this or the 20
steps to do this
no you don't all you need to do is go
back to God's word
remember at the beginning
of this Bible study 2 Timothy 3 16 says
all scripture is inspired by God and
beneficial for teaching for rebuke for
correction for training and
righteousness so that
the man or woman of God may be fully
capable equipped for every good work
God's word is all you need the logos and
also together with the rim a word how he
guides you through the Holy Spirit
that's all you need
so I'm asking you to ask yourself
am I truly following God's word as it is
written am I changing my lifestyle
according to the word or do I want to
interpret or change the word to mean
something it doesn't just so it will fit
in with my lifestyle
that's what a lot of people are doing
today
but that means if you change the word
then you are not practicing what God
wants you
to practice you're not obeying his word
you're creating something that is not
real in your own head
fake religion so let's go back to God's
word
follow him
the second question here is how might
God make you better equipped to serve
him
now I'm just thinking here I wonder what
many of you will answer to these two
questions
how about this how about you answer it
and you put it in the comment section
then we have a little bit of Fellowship
together
number one do you change the Bible to
fit in with your lifestyle or do you
change your life to fit in with the
Bible
two how might God make you better
equipped to serve him
add in the comment section and then if
you want to get my book and go through
all the other 90-day devotionals it will
really help you I talk about a lot of
things like
what it means to be a real reborn
Christian
how to worship God in spirit and in
truth
how to fight spiritual Battles Through
the spirit and not the flesh
what is the role of a husband in
marriage
how to come to the point of complete
surrender
and so much more
nah I just want to say it again to grow
spiritually stronger as a man
you need to put God first in your life
you need to study his word remember the
word of God is sharper than a two-edged
sword cutting to the vision between Soul
and Spirit if you want to become
spiritually stronger you need to
understand God's word you need to write
it on your heart and then live it
it's a lot of people who also know the
word of God
but I don't apply it in their lives you
can know scripture but if you if you
just quote it and say it and and work
with it in the flesh it means absolutely
nothing
you need to understand
to read the word through the holy spirit
that is helping you revealing the truth
to you so that you can understand it and
then apply it in your life
now if you want to get my new book
[Music]
here it is bold Pursuits the book is
also available as an ebook and an
audible version as well now just to make
it a bit more special I want to read
what's on the back of the book because
this is so important
you could pursue a lot of things in life
money relationships power
but only one Pursuit brings satisfaction
on Earth because only one Pursuit
matters for eternity
becoming a true man of God
the action orientated teachings in bold
Pursuit will Challenge and equip you to
pursue God above all else in your daily
life
I mean what can be more important than
that
nothing
as you dig deep into God's word you'll
experience the Fulfillment of making
your relationship with Jesus your
greatest priority
through each day's straightforward
devotional reading packed with powerful
biblical insights you'll explore how to
worship God in spirit and in truth what
it means to engage in spiritual battle
Watson is and isn't and why it matters
where to find hope when you're feeling
hopeless
practical ways to overcome destructive
habits and addictions and how to make
Bible study and prayer in integrated
part of your life
each daily reading in bold Pursuit
combines a Bible passage with a short
devotional that speaks to the real
issues men face at work and home
prayer prompts reflection questions and
action items bring Focus to each day
and it was special for me to go through
one of these days together with you
so you now you know what to expect with
the other days as well
in an age of distraction and busyness
Every Man's true calling Remains the
Same
listen carefully
to walk with God
who created you for great things and
find demeaning and purpose your soul
craves
guys thank you so much for doing this
Bible study with me I love you and I'll
see you in the next video bye